this is how they escape
in fast-moving convoys of buses
because this is the only safe route out
the southern port city of mikaliv is
under attack
it could be surrounded by russian troops
soon
the piles of old tyres on nearly every
street corner are primed with molotov
cocktails they hope when lit the smoke
will slow down their enemy
but shelling overnight injured 53 people
including seven children and the
hospitals are getting busier
this residential area here was shelled
just a few days ago and when the shells
fell
the explosion caused all the glass in
this building and the other building to
shatter
the fighting isn't far from here now in
fact russian forces are said to just be
a few kilometers away to the east
those people who are able to leave have
now left this city but many more have no
choice but to stay
soft
larissa tells us she can't leave she's
got two grandchildren to look after
their parents work at the hospital
i had a different opinion of russia but
after all the explosions bombing when
all the windows are shaking when i'm
holding my grandchildren in my hands now
i've changed my mind the only thing i
want to say is this is my homeland
but this is no place for children
not now
half of the city's population has fled
250 000 people gone
the governor of this city told us the
russian advance has slowed and that
people should stay in their own home is
it your opinion that the russian
military here are targeting civilians
and what do you think about that i'm
sure that they're targeting civilians
because it is corresponding with their
goals do you have enough resources here
militarily do you have enough to to hold
the russian military back by no means
the main
resource is our will
but the people of micholiaf will need
more than will to survive
on one of the streets there's a queue
for a clinic
here we meet eight-year-old misha
patiently waiting on a chair
his father is a former soldier and
carries the emotional scars of past wars
he needs the tablets that help him
he tells me he doesn't want his son to
witness war like he has
he understands what is happening he
understands who the aggressor is
yesterday he
cried hurt me when he said
what does putin want from us
when will this war end
are you worried about what's happening
around you
my parents wake me up and tell me about
the bombing he tells me
and the first thing we do is hide in the
shelter to save ourselves
tomorrow is misha's ninth birthday
he'll spend it here
hoping it'll be a good day
nick martin sky news mika live